Heat.
[Music]
[Applause]
Heat. Heat. Heat.
[Music]
[Applause]
Hello and welcome to another episode of
What's Up Prof. Goodday Walter. Hello,
Martin. And are you doing okay?
Uh, yes. And yes. Is the frog under
control?
Well, if if you start talking, the the
frog seems to want to chip in. Kermit,
we have to keep going. Well, actually,
it should chip in, right? But it's
chipping in.
Yeah, we should keep keep Kermit under
wraps. Yeah. Yes. Kermit must come under
control. Yeah. No. So, it's they say
this thing will last 3 weeks if you
treat it and if you don't try treat it,
it'll last 3 weeks. Okay. So, just let
it be.
That's right. Seems like it.
It's 21 days without treatment and uh 3
weeks with treatment. With treatment.
Yes.
Well, we're stirring again. Why not?
Yeah. Isn't that part of the job
description? Well, it seems like
everybody wants to put everything into a
pot like different religions and
everything. So, we can stir it, can't
we? Yeah, let's stir it. Uh, do you like
the backdrop, Martin? Yes, I I actually
do. Hey, project 2025. Make America
great. Oh, no. Catholic again. That's
naughty. I see there's a rosary behind
the hat, too. Or under the hat. Yeah.
Well, they keep on talking about prayer
and prayer, but they've got a different
um view on prayer than Absolutely. So
Martin, I think uh we're heading for
uh sort of a fulfillment of things
prophesied. So perhaps we need to pray.
For sure we need to. Let's pray. Our
heavenly father, we are surely in
momentous times and we are very thankful
that we can be here, but we also can't
do it without you. So we ask that every
step of the way and every um minute of
this talk that you will enlighten our
minds and guide the discussion in Jesus
name. Amen. Amen.
There's a lot of interesting things and
uh background noise taking place in the
world. A few elections that have been
interesting. the one in Canada and the
one in
Australia and uh the Trump factor.
Yeah, it's Yeah, it's
interesting. In some of the countries,
like for instance, Canada, they were it
was it wasn't expected that the they
were 27 points ahead the conservatives
and then the Trump factor came in and
they wanted to, you know, keep the
status quo. So they went for the left
again. And some of the other states are
very upset because they didn't want to
have another leftist government. Some of
them are even saying they have more in
common with the United States and might
join them. That would be interesting.
Trump has been talking about a 51st
state the whole time. Yeah. Maybe he
gets it piece by piece. Yeah. A little
bit by a little bit. And the other
interesting one, of course, is
Australia.
uh which again has seen something that
is not according to the polls, right?
No. And one thing that was interesting
is the party that won, they also wanted
to or are trying to implement a tax that
is quite ridiculous. Yes. And in
England, something else that's
interesting is that
uh the party that is not to the right
actually won and now in the
bi-elections, it seems that the the
right is making gains again. So, you
know, it's it's it's a very mixed bag
out there.
But looking at it from a prophetic point
of
view, the second beast of Revelation
chapter 13
is going to set the
pace. That's what the Bible says.
There's no doubt that that second beast
is the United States of America. It can
be no other there can be no other
interpretation of that
and then the rest will follow. So the
turmoil that we have is actually trying
to gain the ascendancy so that that
implementation will become a
possibility. So all of these things are
very fascinating but America has to set
the pace and boy has it been setting the
pace. Yes. And then you have the king of
the north and the king of the south
scenario. And we know that they sat at
one table.
And then the king of the north will come
with chariots and with economy and with
ships and you name it and he'll overrun
the king of the south. And we know that
the king of the north is uh the papal
system. Yeah. It must regain what it
lost. The wound that it received must be
restored. And is this happening in the
United States or is it not? I mean, just
cast your mind back to the first
Catholic president
JFK. What a discussion it was just prior
to that. If somebody even just thought
about something like that, then there
was a huge hoo-ha.
And uh he of course distanced himself
very strongly from the union of church
and state. Yeah.
But uh the Bible predicts that the
second beast
will act on behalf of the first beast
which is
Catholicism. And therefore we must
expect a ascendancy of
Catholicism but sort of hidden in
evangelicalism so that you don't really
see him as the driving force but is this
unfolding in the United States or is it
not? Then the answer is yes it is. You
see the popularity of Catholicism is
picking up very very big in and why is
this possible? Because people have lost
sight of doctrine. That's true. The
issue at stake in the world is no longer
doctrine. The issue is social
reformation.
You have to unpack that a little bit
because that's that's exactly what's
happening. That's exactly what happened.
Right. So the issue in the reformation
as we did in the previous one was purely
doctrinal. What was the position of
Christ? How does salvation work? And the
two systems are diametrically opposed to
each other. We did that in the last one.
So the issue of doctrine and how do we
relate to the scriptures and what is the
the role of the scriptures?
Protestantism
said it is central. M solar script is
our guide. It is our our beacon. It is
our lighthouse. This is the way to
navigate.
Catholicism said no. It is tradition
that sets the framework for interpreting
scripture and not scripture that sets
the framework for interpreting
tradition.
So that's putting the cart before the
horse. M and
doctrinally never the twain could meet.
It is an impossibility. Yeah. Because if
you accept the atonement as the way to
salvation as opposed to rejecting the
atonement as the way to salvation and
implementing worksbased religion, the
two cannot meet.
So the solution to the problem was to
over time
escalate social unrest and
chaos. So that the issues that plague
humanity today are no longer based on
doctrine
but rather based
on social issues.
poor poverty, the divide between the
rich and the poor, ideological divides.
Uh whereas parties were generally pretty
close to each other, now they are so far
apart that they're almost willing to go
to war with each other and blow each
other to smitherines.
So how do you how do you combat the
social cataclysms, the demise of
society, the degeneracy of uh humanity,
the moral
issues and the answer is back to a
system that had that under control
and that was in the Catholicism. Yes. in
the middle ages and and they look to one
man for guidance and that is the pope.
So how did it happen
that solos
script suddenly went out the
window. How did it happen? Well
firstly you had to create division
different interpretations. Yeah. So you
had Protestantism and you had
Catholicism. Protestantism from the
onset was never really united. No, it
had aspects of
unity. Wasn't united. Calvinism remained
Calvinism all of the sudden right right
there. It didn't even have unity at the
beginning. No, from the beginning it was
already and then it got fragmented more
and more and more. And as people studied
the scripture, as we've done this many,
many
times, the unity didn't come about, but
the denominations multiplied.
So you started off with a handful. You
had the Lutherans in Germany, you had
the Calvinists in Switzerland. Uh then
eventually that progressed to uh
Scotland where the Calvinists via John
Knox uh introduced their doctrine. Then
you had the church of England and all of
them were basically church and state
united
because that was the thinking of the
middle ages and then that church and
state unity was disrupted after the
French Revolution.
And then you had the demise of the
kings. The kings were seemingly thrown
out. Yeah. And if they were retained,
they had a ceremonial role. Uhhuh. Like
currently. Yes. But if you look behind
the scenes, they're very very prominent
in secret societies. Yes. And the royals
actually lead many of the secret
societies. Yeah. All right. So if you
take the grand masters of of the lodges
in in the Scottish right or in England
or wherever the royals are very highly
represented in that issue. So they
seemingly went underground. Democracy
took the
place and
democracy multiplied the
systems. And so eventually the churches,
Martin,
they kept dividing and splitting on
issues. So eventually you had thousands.
Yeah. All claiming the scriptures. M and
then how do you get them away from the
letter of the word? Thy word is a lamp
unto my feet and a light unto my path.
Thy word is truth. How do you get them
away from Well, you break it down little
by little and you put the emphasis. Yes.
You you use science for example. First
you negate uh Genesis,
then that becomes a
mythology. Then you negate uh the
portions in the scripture that relate to
that or seem to defend the Genesis
account. You break that down so that
there is
a
a let's say a watering down of the
absolute literal
uh interpretation of the scripture
and you bring that through the whole of
society and the Jesuits did a great job
learning against learning setting up the
universities
secularizing them taking the scripture
out. Yeah, as a basis for what is truth,
what is right and what is wrong. That
was a great move and it took a couple of
centuries to do that.
And then
Martin, you swing the religious system
from a wordbased one to a emotional
religion where the spirit becomes the
norm and not the word. Yeah. So it's
it's changing the authority actually.
Yes. So now your feelings dictate your
religion and now you're ready for an
ecumenical movement. You're ready to get
everybody
together and the need for unity is based
on social issues no longer the word.
Yeah. Yeah. That's so Pope Francis and
all the previous pope said, "Let's have
unity." We all believe in
Jesus. We all believe that when we die,
we go to heaven or we go to hell. So,
let's put all the other doctrinal issues
aside and let's see how we can tackle
the social issues together.
Everybody wants morality. Yeah.
Everybody wants this that and the other.
Let's let's concentrate on what we have
in common and forget all of these other
issues. And that's how it started. And
that's why the popularity was able to
move again back to Kath. Correct. And
now that the world is in a state where
you need this moral emphasis again,
what is the basis for the moral
emphasis? Is it going to be the word?
No.
Definitely not. And no, because that
only creates trouble. Yeah, that's
that's true.
It's like uh Tony Palmer said, yes, God
will sort out God will sort out our
doctrines when we get upstairs. I wonder
why he wrote them all in a book if he
wants to say, "Well, chuck the book
away. Let's sort them out later." Right?
It doesn't make any sense. But that's
what they did. God will sort those out.
Let's let's concentrate on the social
issues
and we need strong leadership. Mhm.
What's the biggest church?
Isn't it Catholicism? Yes. And isn't it
influence rising everywhere? Definitely.
And who do they look to for guidance?
The Pope. Remember John Kerry who said
that the Pope is the moral leader of the
world. Yes.
But he needs some clout.
And how does he regain that clout? Well,
enter the second beast. Yeah. So for
years we have been saying that the
second beast will implement
papal doctrines, norms and moralities
again. And it is a
very spectacular
Mhm.
system, one that attracts through its
mysticism and the aims and objectives to
help humanity to get back to
morality. They seem so noble.
Yeah. Never mind that the scripture is
buried and with it the role and
centrality of Christ. The other
important thing is
Martin that the early reformers and the
Roman Catholic
system firmly believed that church and
state needed to be united. Yeah. Because
what's the point of having a system of
morality if it's never implemented?
Don't you need the police to make sure
that it's implemented? Because it's for
everybody's good. It's for the common
good. All right. Now, you're supposed to
make a a personal decision to accept
salvation. That's according to the
Bible. To the Bible. And you must make a
personal decision to come into
harmony with the principles of the
Bible. The Ten
Commandments. Let's get into harmony
with the principles of the Bible.
Now, Catholicism says, you know, our
moral standards and norms are not based
on scripture. They're based on natural
law. So, we're not going to base it on
scripture, but we'll make it almost a
look alike. Yeah. But it's not going to
be a it's not going to be alike. It's
just going to be a look alike. Yeah.
So let's alter the ten
commandments and change them uh to such
an extent that they reflect the needs of
society rather than the requirements of
God. Yes, it makes sense. It makes
sense. That's exactly what they did. All
right. I am the Lord thy
God that took you out of Egypt. Mhm. You
shall have no other gods besides me.
That is a very specific deity. The one
that took them out of Egypt. That is the
true
God. You shall have no other gods beside
me. Well, who besides who?
Uh could be a generic god. Now that's
now the the Catholic changed version.
Yes. So that's the Catholic change
version. You said it stops there. It
stops there. So now you have a generic
deity. Whereas in the scriptures, you
have a very specific deity. Which one
are you serving?
The the lawgiver. Which one? The one
that took the children of Israel out of
Egypt. That is the God. The one who at
Sinai spoke and wrote his law down with
his finger. Yeah. The one who created.
That's the one. That's the one that
you're supposed to serve. You shall have
no other gods beside me. But how you
going to get people to reconcile with
the law like that, Martin? No. You take
away some of the words that make it
specific to which God, is that a good
idea? Well, of course. Well, it'll serve
what? It will it serve the community or
will it serve God? The community. Ah,
okay. So, for the sake of
turmoil, let's just say all the
religions have the same God. Yeah. Was
that the case in the Old Testament? Did
all the nations have the same God?
Definitely not. Didn't uh Paul actually
define it? Yes. And didn't he say that
that which the Gentiles offer, they
offer to demons? Yeah. They offer to
devils. Yeah. Yeah. Right. And I do not
want you to be a partner or a partaker
of the devil's table.
So according to the scripture, not all
deities were the same. Definitely not. I
mean even if you go to Elijah, why did
he have a a whole car experience with
her? What will that philosophy work in
an ecumenical
worldview society? Not at all. It's a
problem, right? It's a big problem. So
who created the problem? God. Yeah.
According to them, according to the
scriptures, he created the problem. He
said, "Nobody else, just the one who
took them out of Egypt, that one who
stood on Sinai and wrote the law with
his finger, that
one. Uh let's let's just make that a
little bit more
generic." Now, the Hindu deities,
they're
welcome. The Islamic deity that doesn't
have a
son, welcome. the shaman's deity.
Welcome. Everybody's now welcome. Now
let's talk. Let's not talk
doctrine. Let's talk social issues.
There's so much poverty, so much
hunger, so much strife amongst
religions. What is causing this strife?
Why does the jihadist want to wipe out
the Christian? And why is the Christian
so stubborn as to not accept the the
deity of the jihadist? Let's put that
all the side. And so didn't Pope Francis
say all
religions lead to the same God. Yeah, he
did. And then everybody must be friends.
Faliti.
Falituti. So let's get rid of the first
one. And idolatry, a bit of a problem.
Thou shalt not make for yourself an
idol. M
uh that's not going to work. No, because
it it already excludes many religions.
So, what are you going to do with
Hinduism? Yeah. With all those idols,
what are you going to do with Buddhism?
Ancestor worship. What are you going to
do with ancestor worship? That's that's
not going to work. I mean, let's just
get rid of it, right? So, drop that
commandment. Then we can worship Patcha
Mama in the Vatican and we can show
solidarity and everybody's going to be
happy.
Much more sensible, right? No. Oh, okay.
And don't take the name of the Lord in
vain. But now you don't know which Lord
you're talking about. So let's let's
regard them all as equal. Exactly. He
said, "Don't speak evil of anyone or
don't speak against any of them." Then
you're a naughty boy. So that's what
Pope Francis said. They're all the same
now. Okay. Is that still biblical? No,
not at all. Remember the Sabbath day to
keep it holy. Six days shall you labor?
But the whole world was sun
worshshiping. That's a bit of a tall
order to go and switch everybody to the
seventh day. Let's stick to the first
day. And after all, Jesus rose on the
first day of the week. So, let's not
bother with that one. But it's the law
of
authority. I am the Lord, the one who
made heavens and earth. Therefore, I
command you. No, no, no, no. Let's let's
keep it generic. Everybody's on another
page here. Just a couple of them are a
little bit cuckoo and want to do that,
right? But let them do it on their day.
So, let's just say, isn't it um keep the
Sabbath day holy and that's it. And you
know, that's what that says now. Honor
your father and your mother
that you may have a long life,
right? Or let's take the promise out.
Just say honor your father and your
mother. But let's bring in natural
law. Uh the one who really needs to be
protected is the child. Yeah.
So let's make some human rights and
let's put child right above parental
right
so the state and the school can
decide what gender your child is. Oh,
well, your child doesn't belong to you.
Even you didn't see when that child came
out and had no clothes on what gender it
was. That's something that the state or
the system will decide for you later.
And if you interfere with that, we will
remove your child because child right is
above parental right. So, let's just
turn that commandment right round.
Right. We could go through the rest of
it. We don't have to but that's the
important ones. So Martin the word is
not
norm. It is how Catholicism has
interpreted it and put it down in their
form of ten
commandments that seem to overlap with
the biblical
ones but totally eviscerate them. Yeah.
Would you agree with a statement like
that? Oh, for sure. indefinitely and
that is the basis of ecommenism
and everybody is on that
page. So at the council of
Trent when uh the Protestants said solos
script we believe in the Bible and the
Bible alone right the archbishop of Reio
said no you don't you're keeping Sunday
so you're actually listening to the
norms and standard of the Catholic
Church so just pipe down you are just a
rebellious lot and we will sort you out
and the Jesuits were created for that
purpose we'll bring you back to the
normal and standards dictated by the
church. And let's forget about the
Bible.
So that's basically in a nutshell how it
happened, how we got to where we are
today. And now we're going to go into a
system where the world is in turmoil and
again needs strong moral guidance.
Back to Catholicism. Not the word. Yep.
Back to Catholicism. and its
norms and because doctrine is not
important but society and the common
good and the need of society is
important. Therefore, nobody will even
notice. No. When we implement procedures
and laws and things which contradict
what the Bible says, but society really
needs them. And it fits right in with
this ecommenical love preaching.
Well said. So let's cut out doctrine
alto together. It's not important. Go
with the flow.
Now Martin, what if somebody says I'm
not going with the flow. Then for the
sake of the social society and all of
that, let's just get rid of them. Okay.
So any any divergent voice needs to be
silenced, right? Uh they don't know how
to do that though or or have they
practiced it recently in in the world?
How to silence certain voices even if
they talk sense? You you say that
they're talking nonsense.
Well,
it Yeah. Well, if we have a naughty
backdrop, Martin, we might as well have
naughty talk, right? We can. I mean,
five years ago, you wouldn't have had
talk like that so blatantly and you
wouldn't have ostracized people so
easily, okay? Like they've in the media
like they've done in the just because
somebody went against
the acceptable norm according to them.
Okay. So Martin the point of the matter
is the Bible predicts that the first
beast which is
unequivocably
Catholicism is going
to recover. The wound will be
healed and the one that will implement
its norms and standards on its behalf
will be the second beast which is the
United States of America.
The question is not is that possible.
The question is is it happening? That's
definitely someone what must happen.
Number one, the stature of
Catholicism must seem to rise again.
Yes, it like it must be become popular.
Number
one. Number two, the moral
voice that emanates from that
source must be regarded as paramount.
They've worked very hard at that, right?
Both the left and the right. For sure.
If you take Kerry's speeches for example
on the issue, that must be elevated
again, but it must become hyperbolic. It
must increase. Yeah. Yeah. It must be a
hero that's coming. Correct. But it must
still seem to be passive
in the
background. So it needs a proxy. Some
Yeah. Somebody that's will do it on his
behalf. The bulldog. You know, they talk
a lot about proxy like the Houthis and
all of those being proxies for Iran,
etc. So you need a proxy that says you
know this is what we need. We need this
moral
stature and what did that pope say and
what did this pope say and what did that
pope say? We shouldn't forget those
things. And what is the new pope going
to say? That's going to be very
interesting. Definitely. And everybody I
think will get to the point where they
say now that is a voice of reason in the
times that we are living in. I think so
too. And we should go back to those
norms and standards. But you need a
proxy.
All right. So introduced the
proxy. Now church and state was such a
wonderful system because whatever the
church decided the state used to
enforce. It was wonderful. Both were
happy. Mhm. And that has gone right out
the window. We need it back, right?
Yeah. Yeah. Church and state must come
back. So the separation of church and
state was a bad idea for the common
good. Definitely. And we need to rule
again, right? Yeah. That's this is how
the church feels now. This is how the
church feels. Yes. We need to rule
again. And
uh the Jews did they feel that they had
to rule? Definitely. Yes. And the
Messiah was going to take that rule away
from them. And the emphasis was going to
be on him and what is happening in
heaven. And what is their role then down
here? Well, that was according to
scripture what you said. But they in
their thoughts that wasn't what they
wanted. No, no, no. They wanted to rule
and in the middle ages they managed to
rule
and now they lost that rule and they
want it back. Yeah. So we need to get
church and state back together again. So
Martin if this happens then then the
playbook that we have which is the word
of God. Yeah this
one
is vindicating itself for sure. So let's
have a look at what's happening in the
world. Now Martin Pope Francis was very
strong on the environment.
the renewable
energy. But somehow there must be a
balance because uh Donald Trump comes
along and says droll baby drill. and it
immediately gets out of the paris accord
and all of that and yet uh you know the
issue mustn't go away because the papal
voice has stature
right so I find it very interesting that
Spain had this calamity when Spain's
100% renewable energy
milestone followed by a historic
blackout and was that coincidence
So for the first time they were bragging
that their grid was based 100% on
renewable energy and then it conked a
few days later. Yeah. People couldn't
get out of their trains because the
doors were locked. They had to force
open the doors. There was a panic in the
a big panic. Big panic and nothing
worked. So for the first time, the
entire national grid just
dissolved. So 12 days later, Spain,
Portugal experienced one of the largest
ever blackouts. The power cut also
affected parts of France, and Pandora,
Belgium, Netherlands, Iberian grid,
disconnected from the wider European
grid, etc. And the cause, well, we don't
really know. Was it temperature? Was it
a pulse? whatever it
was. But uh panic
and they were a few hours without um
power and it was panic, panic, panic,
panic, panic, panic. I think all these
people should come to South Africa.
Yeah. And live here for a while because
our grid is always off. It's We've got
more It stabilized a while and then what
a few weeks ago it crashed again. Yes.
Sorry. Yes. If you if you've ever driven
in Johannesburg and you think that you
can get a traffic light that works, well
then think again. So all of these things
we we're totally used to them. So we
actually smile when these things happen.
Yeah. And but Martin, it's just part of
the chaos that needs to be sorted,
right? It needs to be sorted. And the
sorting will have to come with religious
emphasis, you see, but maybe also that
happening and Trump that's against all
of this, it elevates his his position,
right? His his stature. So, let's go a
little bit back to March the 25th.
That's not very long ago, by the way.
No.
when
Archbishop LPus presents the sacred
cross to President Trump at Greek
Independence Day celebration. Now this
is very interesting. So the archbishop,
the Orthodox Archbishop presents this
special cross and he says and he
compared the president leadership to
that of Emperor Constantine the Great.
Now if we go back in history, uh
Constantine was of course a very
important emperor. Mhm. Because he made
Christianity official in the Roman in
Rome. Not only did he make it
official, but according
to documents which some claim were
thoroughly
forged, he basically handed the
government over to the bishop of Rome on
a plate. Uhhuh.
So that he could rule not only in
religious affairs but in secular affairs
as well. So this is the legacy that he
left to the Roman Catholic Church
basically. And the bishop of Rome that
is now the pope. That's the pope. Yeah.
Correct. So
Constantine embraced
Christianity but he didn't let go of
paganism. No.
So if you go to his big memorials,
Christianity is depicted on the one side
and Mitraism, sun worship is depicted on
the other
side. And actually he unified paganism
and Christianity. That's synratism.
So it stopped the the wars and the
persecution against Christians, but not
because the Christians actually won.
Yeah. They were uh joined up. It's
actually the the mo more dangerous one.
It's a much more dangerous. Syncratism
is a toxin in a very acceptable drink.
Yeah. Deception. Anyway, so he compared
him to Constantine and with that history
backdrop, I'm quite happy with that.
That's true because it's it's a what the
Bible says will happen. Yes, it's
basically the same. So recalling Roman
the Roman ruler's vision of the cross as
a symbol of divine victory. While
handing over the cross, Archbishop
Alpidopherus referenced the emperor's
famous vision. This cross is the very
symbol that led Constantine to victory
as Jesus revealed to
him. So, President Trump was visibly
moved, accepted the gift with
gratitude, and acknowledged its deep
significance.
So Martin, what was
the effect of what Constantine did? He
elevated the position of the bishop of
Rome above all other Christian bishops
in the entire world and basically set up
the papacy as a consequence.
So if you can take that as a type is
this a comparison parallel? It can be
amazing. Would it be an interesting
parallel? I think it could be. Right.
And then on March 19,
2025, faith leaders gathered around
Trump to pray in the Oval Office and it
was called an incredible day.
So from across the country they visited
Donald Trump and they prayed with the
commanderin-chief. The White House
posted an image of the leaders gathered
in prayer around
Trump as he sat at his desk. In
February, Trump signed an executive
order to establish the White House Faith
Office.
Now we we're having a a progression
here. Yes. This is the first thing that
he wrote into with the um executive
order and Paula White is the main
advisor to Trump. Okay. And this office
is in the White House very close to the
Oval Office in the West Wing. That is
very symbolic by the way. And it's the
first time Yeah.
that such an
organization has been given a footprint
in the White House. It's like church and
state coming together. Right. Well, I
can't think of a better way of putting
doing it. So, it's part of the domestic
policy council. The order states the new
office will consult with faith leaders
on various topics including defending
religious
liberty. Now, that sounds very noble.
Mhm. But we must remember how Pope
Francis and Catholicism defines
religious liberty.
Religious liberty is
always defined within the constraints of
the common good. Yes. So you're not free
actually to do just as you like. You can
do as long as it you can have your
denominational
preference or your religious faith
preference as long as it doesn't
interfere with the common good.
Now what if they are united on an issue
and you
distance yourself from it? then you
don't have religious liberty because
you're not working within the framework
of the common good.
So the religious liberty only works if
it satisfies the requirements of the
common good. That's similar to free
speech according to them. As long as you
don't say anything we don't want you to
say. Yeah. So on Wednesday evening,
Trump's Mara Lago residence in Palm
Beach, Florida will host the Catholics
for Catholics
gala. Now that also fascinating. So here
you had this organization, this
faith-based
organization
planted within the White
House. Paula White, of course, is an
evangelical.
But now he had a very special day just
for Catholics. Yes. At his residence. At
his residence. And speakers at the event
included retired Army General Michael
Flynn and veteran political consultant
Roger Stone
etc. And this is their
website. Catholics for Catholics.
Catholic prayer for America gala 2025 at
Mara Lago inspiring a new wave of
Catholicism and patriotism in America.
Are they getting a special boost? For
sure they pushing it. And it's in it's
also very important to remember that
this is the
conservative Catholics prevatican 2
Catholic supporters. They actually just
need a conservative pope to cement
issues. Right. The other word that we
used last time as well is this is
traditional Catholics. Traditional
Catholics. Catholics for Catholics is
fighting to bring the Catholic faith
back into the public square through
rosary rallies, media, political action
and
more through doctrine. Martin, not no no
doctrines. Let's that aside. Let put
that aside. Let's have rosary rallies.
Now, praying the rosary is a repetitive
prayer. 10 Hail Marys, one our father.
10 Hail Marys, one Our Father. And the
Bible clearly says that you shouldn't do
that. No.
State your case plainly. Speak to God as
to a friend. Come unto me all that are
weary and heaven heavy laden. Lay your
burdens at my feet and I will give you
peace. That's it. And political action.
Is that part of the Bible? No. Church
and state. Render unto Caesar what is
due unto Caesar and unto God what is due
unto God. So while Catholics for
Catholics is a movement of passionate
activists, we know that without prayer,
our work is in vain. So repetitive
prayer is the answer. Yeah. That's I
think one of the reasons we've got the
rosary right there under the
hat. We dodged a bullet figuratively and
literally as a country in the last
election. It is time to give thanks to
God and to employ his help for many
battles ahead of
us. Uh are they on a war footing? Oh for
oh definitely. So what is the aim? To
put Catholic norms and standards back
into the administration. And there is
also a little subliminal heat in this
towards Trump. Yes. That this is their
guy. This is the one that's going to do
it. Okay. So let's see how the
conservative Catholics feel about this.
Here is a shot. You can't see all the
priests, but there's over a hundred
priests. This is the statue of Our Lady
of Fatima that was gifted to not just
Donald Trump but to his whole family. It
was a very beautiful statue of Our Lady
of Fatima. High quality one I could
tell. And uh Bishop Strickland prayed a
beautiful prayer. Uh blessed it
sprinkled with holy water with I think
some people saw this image and they're
like, "Oh, big old con celebration in
the middle of dinner." No, that's not
what this is. This is the blessing of
the statue of Our Lady of Fatima as a
gift to the Trump family. And Bishop
Strickland prayed in particular that
this beautiful image of the blessed
mother, it would be a compass leading
them to Jesus that she would say to
them, "Do whatever he tells you to do."
Uh, Martin, what we just
witnessed, is it against the second
commandment? Definitely. Blessing of
statue. Is it against the second
commandment? Definitely. No image. Did
you hear a peep from Protestantism? No.
Not a peep. No.
Okay.
Uh, is it scriptural? No.
Definitely not. Definitely not. Right.
So Martin the whole system there is
paganism that if you look at patcha mama
what what's the difference? Same thing.
So it doesn't matter whether it's the
one or the other. Now I don't want to go
into marology. This is not the aim of
it. We're we're looking at where it is
going.
But it's not scriptural. So it's not
based on what the word says. It's based
purely on what Catholicism
says. It's interesting that Sky Sky News
I think it was that said that Trump is
acting with all these executive orders
and all of these things that are
happening more like a king than like a
president. That's true. Yeah. So, the
constitution that forbids basically the
union of church and state, although they
now argue it doesn't,
uh, shouldn't it then start with I, the
king? That's a little bit of tongue and
cheek, but yes, he's taking over. He's
doing it his way and he's doing it on
behalf of someone. Oh, for sure. Don't
fool yourself. And then what did he do
on this National Prayer Day?
Trump creates religious liberty
commission on national day of prayer.
That's the 1 of May that this article
came out. So the president says his
administration is bringing
religion back to the
country. Hundreds of faith leaders
representing diverse religious
backgrounds.
Christians, Jews, Muslims, Hindus
amongst others attended the Rose Garden
event which held steps from the o Oval
Office. It featured moments of
reflection with prayer led by prominent
religious figures including Hindu peace
prayer and a Christian
invocation echoing the multiffaith
approach seen in past observances.
So this is fataliti. I wanted to just
ask you is this much different from what
the pope did the whole time? No, it's
what he propagated. Uh does it negate
the first commandment? Yes. Yes. Right.
Yeah. Only but it serves the purpose of
humanity from a human perspective but
not from a divine perspective.
So organized by the newly formed White
House faith office, some officials used
the occasion to offer their favorite
religious verses. The executive order
established the religious liberty
commission joins other religious focused
orders signed over the past three months
including one addressing anti-Christian
bias and another targeting a rise in
anti-semitism at colleges and
universities nationwide.
Now some of these
universities are being
pressurized to uh comply with these
executive orders.
So their tax status is being uh perhaps
rescended. Uh funding is being
withdrawn. So are there economic warfare
measurements taken measures taken to
enforce a particular ideology? Yeah,
definitely. It's so biblical actually
everything right now. Let's let's make
sure people don't misunderstand us.
Do we think that anti-semitism is okay?
Definitely not. No. Do we think that
anti-Christian bias is okay? For sure
not. Definitely not. Do we think that we
have to eliminate Muslims from the
world? No. No. Do we believe that Hindus
should be overrun and removed from this
earth? No.
No. Let's make that quite clear. So,
we're not anti-Christian. We're not
anti-semitic. We're not anti-Hindu.
We're not
anti-paganism in any other sense than
doctrinal. Yeah.
Right. Does God want to reach all of
humanity? Yes. Every tribe and nation
and people irrespective of what they
believe.
If there is only one God and one truth,
then he will call them to that truth.
And it is your free will decision
whether you want to take it or not take
it. Right. There's the crux, the most
important. All right. So, we're not
going to pick up arms, but we're going
to pick up a sword. That one. Only the
word. Yeah. Right. Only the word. That's
our sword. The scriptures say.
So in this setup, we know that this
violates the first
commandment and I have a decision to
make. What party am I going to go along
with? And why is it possible for all of
these different faith-based
organizations to come together in
solidarity? Why is it even possible? You
see, I think the problem that might
occur from with people like when they
say, "Oh, but you're against this."
There's nothing wrong with talking to
other religions being friends with
people in there. But it when it becomes
an
official place, you can't if you accept
all of them as leading to God, then you
are negating what the scriptures say
because there's only one way to God and
that is through Jesus Christ. Right.
Yeah. Now there are Christians
there, but what standard are they
adopting? The papal standard or the
biblical standard? Well, if you negate
all of these other things and you put
doctrine aside, then obviously the papal
one, that's fatality. Yeah, that's a
papal standard. It's not a biblical
standard. Okay, let's continue. Now,
what does Donald Trump actually say
about this? We're bringing back religion
in our country, and we're bringing it
back quickly and strongly.
Because for America to be a great
nation, we must always be one nation
under God. A phrase that they would like
to get rid of the radical left. But Ben,
I don't think we're going to let them
get rid of that. Right. We will make
America rich and healthy again. And why
don't we say rich, healthy, and
religious again? Okay. Should I add that
for this group? Right, Dan Patrick? And
you know, they work right out of the
White House. They've never done that.
That's never been done before. No other
president allowed that. I think you know
they say
separation they say separation between
church and state they told me I said all
right let's forget about that for one
time we said really the separation I
don't know is that a good thing or a bad
thing I'm not sure but whether there's
separation or not you guys are in the
white house where you should be and
you're representing our country and
we're bringing religion back to our
country and uh it's a big deal I created
created a historic White House faith
office in the West Wing. And that's
going to be an office that's been very
well. I see already you have a lot of
people going back and forth. And that's
good. That's why we want to defend and
represent people of all faiths and their
religious freedoms at home and at and
abroad. And I wanted him to have that
office. Never happened before. I don't
think that's ever happened before.
Right. The people of faith have never
been allowed in the White House. will
probably be sued tomorrow because
they're gonna say church separation of
church and state can't do that, right?
But we'll win. Pam will Pam will win
that suit. She wins them. She She
ultimately She wins them. She gets them.
Sometimes they get a little a judge
that's not so good, but she ultimately
wins. That's what it's all about, right,
Pam? I signed an executive order to
combat anti-semitism. It's a big thing.
A big
thing. and I set up a DOJ task force,
which is really a big thing, and Dan,
you're going to be involved in it, to
eradicate anti-Christian bias. You
haven't heard that, but there's
anti-Christian bias also. And in just a
few moments, I'll also be signing an
executive order creating a presidential
commission on religious liberty, which
is really why we're here. The chairman
is Texas Lieutenant Governor Dan
Patrick, whose idea this was. And stand
up, Dan.
What a great guy. What a great political
person. He's a amazing politician,
Lieutenant Governor. And he's a very a
man of great religion. Thank you very
much, Dan. As well as Dr. Ben Carson.
Ben, I don't have to say much about Ben.
I don't have to say
much. He's been with me from the
beginning. You know, he was campaigning
against me originally. Can I tell that
story, Ben? You mind? Are you sure you
don't mind? Because he was campaigning
and he was very effective and he was
going up in the polls and and uh he
looked at me about three or four debates
in and he said, "You know you're going
to win by a lot, don't you?" This was
during
2016. And I said, "What do you mean,
Ben? What do you mean you're you're
campaigning? Don't say that, Ben. You're
campaigning. You have a shot." He was a
little bit behind, but pretty far far
enough. But he said, "You know, you're
going to win. These people can't beat
you. Nobody's going to be able to beat
you." I said, "Why?" He said, "Because
God is with you." I said, "That's
[Applause]
nice." Then he said it once again in the
church. Remember that, Ben? He pulled me
over. He said, "Remember what I told
you? God is with you." There's never
been a president who has invoked the
name of Jesus more than you. There's
never been a president who says, "Yes, I
love Jesus, but I live love people of
all faith." As Dr. Phil said, you have a
heart for every American, and you're
showing that today. Um, I'm proud to
represent you as chair, proud to have
Ben Carson as our vice chair and every
member of this committee. We will serve
you, we will serve the people, and most
importantly, we will serve God. Thank
you, Mr. President. And under President
Donald Trump's leadership, faith has not
been pushed aside. It has been brought
back to where it always belongs. And
that is center.
We're bringing back religion in our
country. And we're bringing it back, as
I say, bigger and better and stronger
than ever before. Thank you all very
much. Now Martin, there is now this
commission for religious liberty and the
chairman is Dan Patrick. I think he's
the lieutenant governor of Texas, right?
So prominent political figure, but
obviously an
evangelical with a heart
for this process.
It's interesting that the vice
president is or the vice chair is an
Adventist.
Now depends how you're going to define
that religious liberty.
If that religious liberty is going to be
defined as serving the common
good, then the next step that is in
project
2025 is the implementation of Sunday
legislation. And initially
maybe they will have room for other
interpretations but according to the
document the the default is Sunday.
So if the consensus becomes very strong
then that would be a papal law as
opposed to a biblical law which says the
seventh day. So it's I'm very interested
to see how this pans out.
So, I'm not going to judge on it until
it actually happens, but I know what
scripture says, what will happen. Yes.
And that worries me. It worries me as
well. And we've got clear instruction
from the spirit of prophecy also
regarding mingling with politics.
So, it's a very very interesting time
period. But can you see how religion has
systematically been brought in and he
admitted that uh there was going to be a
legal implication with regards to the
union of church and state but he said we
will win that one. We're going to
basically scrap this idea of not having
church and statement of prophecy. Forget
about that. Yeah. It's a fulfillment of
prophecy. Oh, for sure. Now, one of the
interesting things he also said was as a
mark of respect for the memory of his
holiness Pope Francis, by the authority
vested in me as president of the United
States, by the Constitution and laws of
the United States of America, I hereby
order that the flag of the United States
shall be flown at half staff at the
White House and upon all public
buildings and grounds.
So this is firstly acknowledging the the
stature of the bishop of Rome, right?
And it's a mark of
respect. What if they implement his mark
of authority eventually? That would be
interesting, right? For sure. For sure.
Now, one of the cardinals that uh is
among the favorites among the
conservatives, he's not the only one
that is a conservative cardinal. There
are others as well that are in
contention.
And Donald Trump himself has mentioned
an American cardinal who is also on the
conservative side. So, there are a
number of them that could be in the
running.
So one of them is Robert
Sara. Five quotes from Cardinal Robert
Sara favorite amongst conservatives to
succeed Pope
Francis. He championed by conservatives
as reflecting the doctrinire and
liturgically minded papacies of Pope
John Paul II and Benedict the 16th. So
you know let's stick to the Catholic
ritual
dictated by tradition by the way is
amongst those being considered to
replace Pope Francis. So a man such as
he would be in line with the general
thinking of the politicians in the white
house at the moment at the moment and
even that Catholics for Catholics group
activist group. Correct. So that's very
interesting. He previously headed the
Vatican charity office core unum and
clashed with Francis on many occasions.
uh their ideologies divide most
seriously came to a head when Sara and
Benedict retired as acting pope in 2013
co-authored a book titled from the depth
of our hearts priesthood celibacy and
the crisis of the Catholic Church where
they argued for the more uh traditional
ways of doing things.
Vance, one of the last dignitaries to
meet with Pope Francis on Easter Sunday
before his passing, has referenced Pope
John Paul 2, ideologically more similar
to Sara in recent public addresses. So
there seems to be a distancing from the
liberal side back to the conservative
side. And as we have said,
Martin, that would be a healing of the
wound. Definitely. Well, can it also be
a healing if it goes back to a liberal
pope that's elected? Well, it doesn't
really matter whether the pope that is
elected is a liberal or whether is a
conservative or whether he is a moderate
somewhere in between. What will heal the
wound is if church and state yes get
together and the the norms and standards
of the church are implemented by
legislation that heals the wound
entirely because that is legislating
legislating Catholic morality on behalf
of the papacy
even if it's contrary to the scriptures.
Yeah. So that would heal the wound. But
Catholicism has always
argued that the system that was in place
in the Middle
Ages where by tradition the stature of
the pope was accepted without question.
They want to get that back again. And
the the rituals that they had kept
people in ignorance. Yeah, that's true.
And We want people in ignorance today as
well because we must focus on the ritual
rather than the word. That's true. I
just wanted to I was thinking now we
were talking like you just said you need
somebody to be actually taking that
place the that will be the popular one.
Yes. Now Pope Francis be we started off
very popular but then but actually if we
look at it and we've mentioned it many
times although he said certain things
that was very
liberal it never he never changed the
doctrine. No the doctrine stayed. Yeah.
And and Vatican 2 did not resend one
single doctrine. And as Bishop Schneider
said they can't because they're excited.
Yeah. They're infallible.
So if somebody gets back to this
infallibility
issue, then Protestantism should really
have a cadenza.
They should have a a fit. They should
have an apoplelectic fit. But I
guarantee there won't be a whimper. They
would actually they support this because
they want this morality to come back.
seeming to have an earthly authority
that they can look at, an earthly
implementation of their power and let's
forget about the kingdom of God because
we're going to set it up and Jesus will
have to look at on from the sidelines
and say, "Well done, my little soldiers
down there. You are now keeping
everybody under control on my behalf
even though you're doing everything
contrary to scripture. Yeah. Just before
we go on when seeing Bishop Sara here um
Cardinal Sara Cardinal Sara sorry in the
previous episode that we did um we
mentioned the black pope. Now maybe just
explain some people got confused and
thought it was a racial issue. It's not
a racial issue at all. It's the dress
that they wear. The black pope is the
head of the Jesuit order. And he also
resides in Rome and is the power behind
the throne. He is the general of the
army and uh he is the one that
implements on the ground what the wishes
are and sees that it gets implemented
and infiltrated into all political
societies. So that's the black pope not
on the basis of his skin color but on
the basis of the robe that he wears.
Then you have the white pope.
He is the one to whom the they swear
allegiance. But they are so united in
their in their work and the aim is again
this ultra montinism all power in one
man
and that is what they want to implement.
If the next pope should be black in in
terms of his color,
well then you could have a joke and say
there will be two black popes, but
really not. It doesn't matter whether
he's white or whether it's black because
it's not a racial issue at all. Yeah,
it's a it's a religious system that is
implemented.
Now this might be very tongue and cheek
but it might actually also be subliminal
for sure even even a bit prophetic. Yes.
In the terms that Trump posted an image
of himself as
pope on his social
network and uh there was a big hu and
cry but there were thousands that loved
it. Right. Hundreds of thousands. Now in
my view I think it was probably tongue
and cheek but it could be prophetic. Not
that he will become pope of course not
that but that he will implement on
behalf of the pope. Oh for sure what
they want. You see he he will be acting
even though he's not pope doing
everything the pope wants. Everything
that he wants. So he'll be acting like
the pope. Yeah. In act actual fact he'll
be doing on his behalf which the pope
wished he could do publicly but he's
doing it clandersteinly like he will do
as the popes would have done in the
middle ages in the middle ages he will
just be the proxy doing it on his
behalf. So the picture was published
without comment or explanation on the US
president's personal account and then on
the white house X and Instagram
accounts. So there was maybe mischief
involved but maybe
uh unbeknown to them or be known a
prophetic implication. Isn't one of the
tricks of the Jesuits that you put in
some a fact in plain sight. Yes, that is
the secret society norm. You hide things
in plain sight.
It comes just a few days after the world
leader joked that he'd like to be the
pontiff. Last week he was asked by
reporters on the White House lawn who he
would like to succeed Francis and he
replied I'd like to be
pope. That would be my number one
choice. He went on to say that he did
not have a preference but there was a
cardinal in New York who was very good.
Well, previously he said Cardinal Burke
was an excellent choice. Now he's
probably referring to Cardinal Dolan.
So either one would be traditionalist if
they came in. So there are a number of
I'm not saying that they will come in,
but it would be interesting if any one
of them did come in. And then as far as
he himself was concerned, he was raised
Presbyterian. So that's Calvinist. But
he has renounced it and he's considering
himself a
nondenominational Christian which is uh
probably a wise move if you want to have
this ecumenical climate which is what
Rome wants. Yeah definitely he has to
actually has to. So what he did is he
put actually the Bible aside. Yes. to
say I'll don't want to affiliate with
anyone so that I can it's like a
Catholic doctrine actually that's like
Catholic it's a very clever
system now Martin let's get to project
because really this is the the playbook
isn't it now this article here from the
20th of March has to do with the
department of
education which brought in so many
liberal ideas that they want to
eradicate it and uh education is a
crucial target of the right-wing policy
wish list known as project
2025. Now this comes from the
BBC. A 900page document calls for
greater school choice, essentially
subsidizing religious and private
schools with public funds, which was
also the subject of an early Trump
executive
order. So the question arises, although
Trump distanced himself from the project
2025, is he actually implementing it?
Because the proof of the pudding is
always in the eating. Exactly.
So he can be very it can be a a word
play that he distances himself but his
whole cabinet are actually part and
parcel or busy with it. Correct. Yeah.
He but he himself is not
uh directly doing it but everything else
is it's like the Catholic Church
distancing itself from Freemasonry while
most of their prominent people are
Freemasons. Right. Yeah. So, while Trump
distanced himself from Project 2025, he
has nominated several of its authors to
fill key government positions and many
of his initial executive orders closely
follow proposals outlined in the
document. So, they're saying, is this
now policy this 2025 or is it a wish
list? M so they've they've downgraded it
from policy to
wishlist. But isn't it the same thing?
If you write an executive order and the
wish list becomes a policy,
of course. That's why I say it's word
play. It's it's clever word play. So is
this a question? Is
2025 the project making America Catholic
again? Is that a good question?
Well, here he's dressed more like like a
Jesuit in a black robe, right? So, is he
uh is he playing a double role? We don't
know. So, the Sky News picks this up and
says, "Is Donald Trump following a
right-wing playbook?" And what's next?
Then they go through a couple of things
that actually were implemented. So,
let's have a look at it.
What project 2025 said? The document
called for the president to slash
regulations and make federal employees
easier to
fire. What has Trump done? From the day
he returned to office, Mr. Trump has
instructed allies to go after the
so-called deep state by bringing federal
agencies, including the FBI and the
Justice Department, much more under
presidential control. So, he did it.
Yeah.
What else did it say? Illegal
immigration should be ended, not
mitigated. The border sealed, not
repprioritized. What did he do? He has
promised tweaking deportations, declared
a national emergency at the border with
Mexico and basically stopped it. Yeah.
99.9%.
So, did he implement it? For sure. Okay.
What else did the project say? The next
conservative president must make the
institutions of American civil society
hard targets for woke culture
warriors. Is he doing it? He's very hard
on that. Is he going after the
universities? Yeah, you just mentioned
it earlier. Okay. One executive order
after the other. It is said this should
be done by deleting terms like
diversity, equity, and inclusion, gender
equality, and abortion. Didn't they stop
all the funding? Didn't Yeah. The
Department of Government Efficiency
under Musk identify all of that and just
stop it. Stop it. The DEI
was immediately gotten rid of in the
first executive order on that first day.
And what was the anger that it invoked?
Aren't they burning Teslas and doing all
kinds of things as a consequence?
They've got protests everywhere. But now
I see there's counterprotests as well
from the Well, this is fine. So what has
he done? He promised a war on woke and
has certainly delivered that. His
executive orders have stipulated that
there are only two genders and sought to
end government support for DEI programs.
while the Pentagon has purged DEI
content from its online platforms. So
that was a a
given. Is that a wish list or is that an
implementation? Well, if you can
use financial means to force people to
do
this, then that is a fulfillment of
Daniel chapter 11. Definitely.
Definitely. You know, this wish list
make me think like you if you go onto
online uh shopping, you got it in your
wish list. Now he's moved the wish list
now to the cart and he's busy. It's in
the cart. Yeah. What else did it say on
the issue of tariffs and trade? The
document is
split. So what has he done? While he has
proved somewhat movable on other
policies, President Trump has spoken of
his love of tariffs for decades. The
series of global tariffs have sent
markets tumbling and left allies
reeling. But there's going to be a new
economic order.
And if he can force the
world, then he must have some clout.
Well,
isn't everybody running around,
scrambling around in inclus including
our country? And can you use the economy
to force ideologies? Yeah. Okay.
Then what else did it say? Federal
education policy should be limited and
ultimately the federal department of
education should be eliminated. So what
did he do? He signed an executive order
calling for the dismantling of the
department of education. You can't you
can't implement it better than that. No.
What next? Well, what did it say? It
also said the next Conservative
administration should scale back US aid
global footprint by at a minimum
returning to the AY's 2019 precoid
pandemic budget level. Has he done it?
Yes, 100%. He's gone far beyond.
Instead, he has moved to dismantle it
altogether. What else did Project 2025
say? The Biden administration's extreme
climate policies have worsened global
food insecurity and hunger. Its anti-
fossil fuel agenda has led to a sharp
spike in global energy
prices. So, let's solve that problem.
And a good blackout in Spain might just,
you know, make his
point. Can you see how all this fits
together? For sure. For sure. So, what
has he done? He has withdrawn the US
from the Paris climate
agreement, revoked President Joe Biden's
gold on electric vehicles, and promised
to drill, baby
drill. So, has he implemented it?
Finished. On the way. Okay. What about
this one? The Supreme Court decision to
strike down abortion protections in Row
versus Wade is hailed as the greatest
pro-f family win in a
generation, but says things shouldn't
stop
there. So, what has Trump done? While
his initial flurry of executive orders
did not include measures to expand or
enforce the Comtock Act, Dr. long said
it is still very early in the
president's term. So Martin this is a a
little long-term agenda. You first have
to get the things in place. Yeah. That
will give you the leverage that you
need. Right. That's true. You can't
implement an ideology
until you have the leverage to enforce
it. Right. Mhm. And you can see how that
is getting together.
What else did the project 25 say? The
wide-ranging playbook for power called
on US allies to take far greater
responsibility for their conventional
defense. What has he
done? Mr. Trump and his administration
have urged NATO allies to spend more on
defense. He's basically forcing them. He
is. He's not just asking them. No.
And then what else? Tik Tok is in effect
a tool of Chinese espionage that should
be outlawed by the president. So Trump
is trying to negotiate a sale of the app
to US
operations. So he's he's playing it by
the book. I'm interested in the next
one. That's it. And it's not us
mentioning it. It's Sky News. Yeah.
Right. Definitely. Let's just make this
quite clear. What's next?
So, what could be next? If Mr. Trump
continues to mirror Project
2025, consciously or
unconsciously, some unrealized parts of
the document include the
following. Its focus on family, which it
says is in crisis.
It adds, "It's time for policymakers to
elevate family
authority, formation, and cohesion as
their top
priority, and even use government
power." Is that legislation?
Yes. Including through the tax code to
restore the American family. with one of
the authors saying every threat to
family stability must be
confronted. What is the number one thing
that the papacy has asked for to bring
the family back to its original purpose?
What was the one thing they asked for?
Sunday legislation. Sunday legislation.
Is that also in the document? That's in
the documentation. But it's already
being had a foothold in Europe for a
long time. The European Sunday Alliance
pushing it the whole time. But if they
ask for this and the number one issue in
terms of making the family viable again
is common time to spend with each other
as a family. in order to not only
further the aims of the family. So it
must be synchronized time. Mhm.
Synchronized time,
Martin. How do you synchronize time?
That means it doesn't help to give mom a
Wednesday off. Yeah. And dad a Sunday
off because then the family is split. M
it doesn't help to have part of the
family subject to school
rules and the other one to work rules.
That's not synchronized time. How do you
get them all together? You must have one
common day of rest. Mhm. Mhm. Can you
have two? No. Can you have three? No. So
what is the default Sunday for sure? And
what did they say in project 2025? What
is the default day? Sunday. So the
argument must be synchronized time to
bring the families together.
That means any other day even if it is
initially allowed for in terms of
religious
liberty must eventually give way to
synchronized time off.
That means only one day per
week can be permissible in order for the
economy not to suffer. That's for the
common good. Therefore, the default will
be
Sunday. Is this next on the agenda?
Well, I think it's very much
prioritized. Well, Sky News asks the
question they do mention the other ones
well as well, but this is the first one.
This is the one that they say what's
next
because I actually hope they're right
for sure. And it says which it says is
in crisis. Yes. So anything that's in
crisis means it's going to get priority.
But before you implement this one, you
must first get the leverage to implement
it not only in the United States but see
to it that it is done
universally and the papacy will play a
very prominent role and Lodatus C and
project
2025 give it a very prominent place in
their document.
mentation. So project
2025 talks about Sabbath rest. God
ordained the Sabbath as a day of rest
and until
evoch Christian tradition sought to
honor that mandate by moral and legal
regulation of work on that day. modern
Judeo-Christian tradition. That means
you must stop all
anti-semitism and all Christian bias. So
that's already they are together.
There's only one little problem here
that the Judeo side keeps the Saturday
and the Christian side keeps the Sunday.
So one now which one of the two? What is
the national banking day of rest?
Sunday. Yeah. Yeah.
Sunday. What is the traditions of the
peoples generally? Sunday. Sunday. So,
Judaism is a a minority when it comes to
that. So, if they insist on the Sabbath,
Saturday, and the Adventists join them,
they'll still be a
minority. And if they want to be
inclusive and have a synchronized day of
rest, then sooner or later one of the
two must give way. Yeah. Which one will
it be? The history will be repeated.
Okay. It will go to the Sunday.
Constantine. Didn't he make a Sunday
law? Exactly the same. And then it was
still
Jewizing having Sabbath and Sunday. And
Catholicism then made an anti-Sabbath
law. That's history.
If uh Donald Trump is being compared to
Constantine,
that means he's acting on behalf of the
bishop of Rome.
Mhm. Then the wishes of the bishop of
Rome, the mark of his
authority, Sunday keeping should be
legislated for and Sabbathkeeping should
be legislated
against. I'm wondering who will
capitulate. Will it be the Jews or will
it be the
Adventists? Let's leave that to
Providence. Let's see what happens.
Right.
So, Martin, moreover, a shared day
off makes it possible for families and
communities to enjoy time off together.
That's synchronized
time rather than as atomized individuals
and provides a healthier cadence of life
for everyone. That's what the document
says. It's the common good. It comes
straight out of paper thinking. So,
Congress should encourage communal rest
by amending the Fair Labor Standards Act
to require that workers be paid time and
a half for hours worked on the Sabbath,
that day would default to
Sunday. That's the mark of the bees.
Yeah.
So whether the chair is an evangelical
or the vice chair is an Adventist or
whether there is a Jew in the fray, the
issue of Sunday versus
Saturday is not going to go away easily.
Who's going to capitulate is the
question and which day will eventually
be enforced in order to have a
synchronized day of rest universally?
Yep. Do you think the labor unions will
play a part? No, they're playing a a
major part. Now, in Europe, are the
major uh labor unions on the Sunday
bandwagon? Definitely. All of them. All
of them.
Martin, we're in for an interesting
ride. And therefore, on that
note, I think we need to pray because I
think the
playbook as it is recorded in scripture
is unfolding before our eyes
and we need that
prayers. Prayers and not their rosary
prayers. No, let's ask God in
simplicity. Heavenly Father, you hold
the reigns of history. We know that
because you predicted history in advance
in the book of Daniel and
Revelation. And now as we see the very
things written there unfolding before
our eyes, it means that we have to make
a choice
between various kings.
Some claim that the kings of this world
will dictate the
morality and the Bible claims that if
you do not adhere to the morality of
scripture then you do not love God
because if you love God you will keep
his commandments and if you do not keep
them you are referred to as a
liar. So, heavenly father, we don't want
to be liars. We want to keep your
commandments and not changed
ordinances that feed the common good.
So, help us to make right decisions is
my prayer in Jesus' name. Amen.
Amen. Heat. Heat.
[Music]